the one of the things that I saw that
just blew me away was there's a man on
all fours like a dog he was burned from
the crown of his head to the soles of
his feet and his eyes were bulging out
just a message saying this app has been
such a game changer to me I've never
been so consistent with my Quran reading
before I knew about quranly you can get
quranly absolutely free no credit cards
for seven day free trial what are you
waiting for you can find the link for
IOS and Android in the link description
below
brothers and sisters and dear friends
I'm here with the honorable gentleman
hey Job how you doing bro alhamdulillah
how's life it's good may I always keep
it good inshallah so okay so if this
video is that something funny yeah he he
is yeah he is that's right yeah he is
yeah I would say you know shaytan is on
my left so is he Sean
okay so one of these I wouldn't call it
Sugar hat but
um usually Christians come with this
stuff basically I died and then my soul
went and I saw Jesus or stuff like that
this man he didn't see Jesus but he saw
his claim that he saw Hellfire so let's
see what he had to say okay this is the
priest yeah he in 2016 he had a heart
attack he died and this is what he saw
yeah you ready
oh yes absolutely I saw the real Hill I
was there and I wouldn't wish that upon
my worst enemy I don't care what a
person has done to me I would never wish
that on them
um but for me the way it went is that I
thought that I was having a heart attack
and uh I physically my my spirit left my
physical body and I thought that I was
going upward but because I thought I had
done so much good in this lifetime and
helped so many people and made so many
decisions that were Godly decisions but
um as opposed to me growing up I went
down and I went literally into literally
into the center of the earth and that
that's where hell is Jesus even said
that in the scriptures he says uh just
as Jonah was three days and three nights
and the belly of a well so shall the son
of man be three days and three nights in
the belly of the earth uh which is where
hell is
um the things that I saw were literally
undescribable it just brings me makes me
emotional every time I talk about it but
uh it was uh one of the one of the
things that I saw that just blew me away
was there's a man on on all fours like a
dog he was burned from the crown of his
head to the soles of his feet and his
eyes are bulging out and it was worse
than that is that he had a chain around
his neck so he was like a dog in hell
and was even worse than that is that who
was holding the chain
it was a demon holding the chain
and I knew it because their things are
not they're not said they're known you
just it's like a telepathic
communication
um I knew that this demon was sent in
this man's life to ride him from his
childhood until the time that he died
because the demon knew that if I could
stay in his life long enough on the
earth if I can keep getting him to not
serve God and to make bad decisions on
the earth then I'll have power over him
in hell and he'll be a slave to me so it
was like twice a slave it's like you're
a slave on the earth to the things of
the devil and then in hell you're you're
really like a tormented dog slave uh so
and then there was another part that I
experienced that just blew me away I
just I'm still baffles me this day if
there was a section in hell where music
was playing
and it was the same music that we hear
on the Earth but as opposed to uh
entertainers singing it uh the music
demons were singing
and there were some of the same lyrics
that we hear here
um and then again things like I said
that they're not things are not
telepathically they're tough things are
telepathically known there I knew that
on earth a lot of the lyrics and the
music and the songs are inspired by
demons so sometimes when people smoke to
get high and to get lyrics and to get
verses and rappers and all those things
so in a lot of music people actually
smoke to get high to give versus and to
get bars and be hard to be fresh and uh
to get that swag but when they open
themselves up uh to just oh yeah yeah
there's a few things that you mentioned
I found it quite interesting um he
talked about dog for the process
he will see his father if I'm not
mistaken in a in the form of like a dog
okay I'm gonna have to check the
ultimate I I I've heard of I'm very sure
but we'll check authenticity and we'll
cut it off if it's not there number one
number two it talks about
um he was in a shackle
and Allah is the one who will
um the way he
um the way he shackles no one will
shackle yeah there's a lot of us but you
know what I found really profound bro
yeah he's a priest he claims to have
died yeah
um there's something that is narrated um
he once was seen he saw a priest coming
towards him yeah and he started crying
and he said well why are you crying and
he gave the eye in Surah where he says
he said they will be coming laboring
exhausted and they would enter the fire
and they said the reason I'm crying is
because I'm looking at this priest and
he doesn't get married he worships God
or Jesus wherever he calls all his life
in that Temple working exhausted
laboring heart and he will enter the
fire yeah I mean all that effort and
everything that he'd done was nullified
because of his shirk so what you make
out of seeing this priest saying that he
went to the Hellfire he heard something
along the lines of Rihanna or the lights
being played well it's something you
can't really falsify it's someone's
experience someone said I had the dream
that they went to hell for example yeah
whether they were in a coma and then
they went to hell fight he can't really
say anything about that there's nothing
in there that
um is so Aboriginal from our perspective
that we would say it's a it's a lie or
anything like that anyway okay so I feel
like you know at the end of the day he
says something in the beginning where he
said that you know I didn't know why I
was doing this and why I deserved it
myself because I was doing good on my
whole life uh um this is this is the
problem of shirk as you mentioned right
so to haid is the idea there's only one
God worthy of worship and shirk is
displacing that worship that should be
given to God to other than God uh
something else someone else Jesus
whoever it may be a human being and we
believe that those who would do that
will go knowing The Message of Islam
knowing the message of tawheed being
given the alternative to worship only
one God will go to the Hellfire
uh and so I don't think this is an
apologia for Christianity in any way in
fact this as a degree of authenticity
that is in this clip because why would
someone you know it doesn't seem like it
has any apologetic value like it doesn't
have any polemical value in the sense
that
he's just giving you he's giving his own
basically a dream that he had or
something like for us as Muslims we
believe the following we believe that
when someone dies
that they will see their place either in
heaven or in hell
yes so that we believe in a certain
stages because this is a question
age-old question what happens when you
die yeah what happens when you die is
that your soul is taken to another place
called
or the the life of the bazaar and in
that you'll see your place in heaven or
hell and for those people who are going
to Hell Fire they will be told they
would not want they have judgment to
commence which is the next stage of this
uh human endeavor if they were
disbelievable yeah for example they were
no they were wanted but this may very
well be a warning to this priest and to
people who follow him because at the end
of the day if he saw the Hellfire yeah
this is maybe a precursor to what's
going to happen to you when you die
maybe I'm not can't say for sure what we
need to do therefore is do some proper
soul searching see what is the true
religion Christianity has a lot of Truth
in it we don't deny that as Muslims we
say that we believe in Christ we believe
in Messiah we believe in the Virgin Mary
but there's something you guys are doing
fundamentally wrong which is that you
are worshiping a man which we believe
this is exactly the ticket to the
Hellfire exactly and I think that's the
reason why you saw yourself like I did
so many good deeds but in the sight of
God
um it's like Mother Teresa you know he
she can do all good these but she she
likes as much as whether it means be
yeah but if you are it's like the
example I give is if I'm good to the
whole world then charitable and Ali is a
charitable guy I go home and I beat my
mom up yeah am I a good person no you
say I'm a bad person so it doesn't
matter what good these you do if you're
violating the rights of the one who
created you just given the credit
belongs to him to another being whoever
it may be then of course you're gonna
deserve Hellfire so that's number one
number two which we haven't touched upon
is the Shabbat some people come and say
you know how is that these Christians go
when they have this uh they have this
experience the question is this in Islam
we do not believe they died because we
believe you die once yeah this concept
of them saying Oh I went to the Hellfire
and I died and that's what Jesus yeah
you didn't die yeah I understand but I
made that clearly of course but like we
have as you know like this there's the
greater death in this uh the Lesser
death yes so for example when we wake up
in the morning yeah uh we are told to
say which basically that is the one that
put us back to life after that we have
died yeah so sleeping because there's a
lot loss of consciousness if you think
about it right why there is more in
common with sleeping and and dying then
there has been being awake and sleeping
for example yep and so because there's a
lack of control loss of consciousness in
both cases and there's a reality which
is outside the physical in both cases
yeah so we don't deny and by the way
this idea like for example that
Christians Jews or any other polytheists
can have dreams which can have value is
something which the Sharia comes into
firms like for example in the story of
Yusuf alaihissalam the the king in that
story had a dream which Joseph Islam did
interpreted so the scholars of Islam say
uh those who have dreams from the
non-islamic or they're not Muslims those
dreams can still carry some weight and
some value so there is we do believe in
something called dream interpretation I
mean it's not something which is far
away from the Islamic Paradigm uh
obviously we believe one of the prophets
did it yeah who does that properly and
who not it's definitely something part
of the religion of Islam mentioned it
yeah so we're not denying the man's
experience like you said we're just
reclassifying it's not the death in the
in the final sense as well exactly
because we need to make that clear
because a lot of basically these people
have died and seen we say in Islam we
believe that yes Dream Sleeping is a
form of a form of like um close to death
but it was not the Ultimate Death that
Allah tells us that every social thing
exactly but some people have a
misconception as if dying and the body
coming back we believe no once Allah
decreed that you died you died you will
never come back to say I died of course
that's the Shabbat so that was it
um and in a nutshell like you said you
know it's made it very clear and
hopefully it's a reminder because uh the
process
he actually had the dream once that he
was held by the angels and brought
closer to the Hellfire and the prophetam
said if only Omar does so many good days
if only he prayed a little bit more at
night so the thing is that is yeah
yeah
so yeah that's what it was so different
dreams can have different
interpretations and that's it and
hopefully you guys have benefited from
this inshallah and that is answered that
little and also for this priest if it's
watching this it was in 2016 it's been a
good seven years that's when I announced
a marriage documentary anyways but yeah
it's been about seven years but
hopefully you can wake up and realize
you know what actually
um this is maybe a wake-up call for you
um and you worship the one true God
hijab thank you very much for your
contribute contribution promises
contribute and contributions
uh brother sisters don't forget to
subscribe uh to my no no his channel
again
so next time
good